[Music]
on this tuesday night back from the
brink
park eve ukraine rebounds
it feels like things are returning to
the way they were before a kiev
kitchen's heartwarming recipe to feed
the recovery if you worry about someone
at first you want to feed them and
canada's latest commitment for military
aid
restoring power to storm-ravaged ontario
and quebec plus the cleanup one of the
trucks is folded in half criticism in
kamloops was this just a photo op
pushback to the prime minister's visit
and allotted canadian author fired up
why margaret atwood is taking a
flamethrower to one of her books
[Music]
global national with donna friesen
reporting tonight chris galas
good evening and thanks very much for
joining us we begin tonight with
breaking developments in another
heartbreaking mass shooting in the u.s
at least 18 children and a teacher are
dead after a shooting at an elementary
school in uvalde texas a small city west
of san antonio jackson proskow joins us
now with the latest jackson
chris this is an unspeakable tragedy the
students were in the second third and
fourth grade that puts them between the
ages of 7 and 10 years old the 18 year
old suspect was killed on the scene we
believe by police officers and may have
had at least two guns in his possession
we know that he is believed to have shot
his own grandmother before attacking the
school today just after 1pm local time
but a motive remains unknown tonight the
news came from the governor of texas
earlier this evening
what happened in juvaldi
is a horrific tragedy
that cannot be tolerated in the state of
texas and there is swift action being
taken by
local law enforcement as well as the
texas department of public safety
governor abbott talks about action there
jackson but we are 10 years past the
sandy hook elementary school massacre
nothing changed after that is there any
reason to hope that american lawmakers
will tackle gun violence this time
it's hard to believe that they will
change their attitude here chris if
nothing changed after sandy hook why
would anything change now here we are
with the second horrific mass shooting
in a week's time in this country and
while lawmakers and average americans
say they're furious
it's hard to believe that things will
change but we could find out more
proposals tonight from president joe
biden he's set to speak shortly all
right we'll see what the president says
jackson proskow in washington thank you
jackson
exactly three months ago russian
president vladimir putin ordered an
invasion of ukraine in the week since
canada has helped ukraine both
financially and with artillery today
defense minister anita anand announced
the federal government is sending more
weapons
can confirm that canada has purchased
over 20 000 rounds of 155
millimeter artillery which is nato's
standard
artillery caliber
this package will also include fuses and
charge bags at a cost
of up to 98 million dollars
anand says the shipment is in response
to specific aid requests from ukraine
and work is underway to make sure the
troops get the weapons as soon as
possible
now russian forces have launched an
all-out assault in the south working to
seize parts of the donbass region but
ukrainian troops have pushed russia out
of harkiev where residents have been
bombarded for weeks with the city's
metro reopening today there's finally
some optimism about a return to normalcy
our jeff semple is in harkeve tonight
and joins us now with more jeff
chris when we visited harkiev back in
march ukraine's second largest city
appeared on the brink of falling to the
russians but today we saw a much
different reality during the first weeks
of war families sheltered underground
huddled together in subway stations to
avoid the bombing above
but two months later their lives are
slowly getting back on track
subway service in harkev resumed tuesday
for the first time since russia's
invasion and commuters were on board
it's excellent it feels like things are
returning to the way they were before
this passenger says
the mayor of harkev whom we met two
months ago in a secret bomb shelter
appeared this time in public
and told reporters we need to restart
the economy people must be able to get
to work
this russian-speaking city sits on
russia's doorstep just 40 kilometers
away but ukraine has pushed russian
forces back almost to the border and it
seems some left in a hurry this was
a russian tank that is until it was
captured by the ukrainian forces in a
battle with the russians in harkev last
month the ukrainians brought it here to
this secret location so that ukrainian
soldiers can train and learn how to use
it so this is a look inside they say
it's similar in many ways but it's a
newer model and it's much faster so they
have to learn how to handle it they say
that this thing can go up to 100
kilometers an hour in fact they've
nicknamed it the flying tank
in three months the ukrainians have
captured more than 240 russian tanks
they say they even use this one to
attack a russian battalion and kill its
commander
our enemy has gone from attacking to
defending this ukrainian sergeant says
our spies say the russians are
demoralized but while the city hopes the
worst is over the scars of war are
brutal
this family survived the bombing of
their apartment building and came to
inspect their son's kindergarten across
the street
they found his school playground full of
fragments from russian rockets
russia says it's attacking military
targets but this is a quiet neighborhood
with schools and houses she says the
family called the ordinance disposal
unit to remove this grad rocket from
beneath the play structure this team has
their hands full
the rockets are everywhere he says in
the span of just a couple of hours his
unit was called to remove ordinance from
this apartment kitchen a nearby parking
lot and yet another kindergarten
playground none of us i'm angry says the
father of a one-year-old
i want to kill the people who did this
with my bare hands officials say about a
third of all apartment buildings in
harkev have been damaged or destroyed
and they've also updated the death toll
more than 700 people killed including at
least 36
children
chris
jeff semple in harkeev ukraine thank you
jeff
russia's jailed opposition leader alexey
navalny labeled vladimir putin a madman
today navalny made the comment in court
while appealing a nine-year prison
sentence for fraud saying the russian
president started a quote stupid war in
ukraine his appeal failed and russian
media is reporting navalny will now be
sent to a high security prison alexei
navalny was arrested february 2021 after
returning to russia from germany where
he was recovering from a near fatal
nerve agent attack navalny blames putin
and his security services
days after a deadly storm tore through
southern ontario and quebec killing 10
people devastated communities are still
cleaning up and late today storm
watchers at western university say it
was in fact an ef2 tornado with wind
speeds up to 195 kilometers an hour that
struck oxbridge ontario on saturday as
mike trolley reports tonight hundreds of
thousands of people remain without power
call it progress however slow it seems
hydro crews bolstered by hundreds of
workers from the u.s are getting
ontario's power grid up and running it's
really the degree of uh the devastation
that's occurred it's very complex
complex to the tune of 1400 hydro pools
and 1 000 kilometers of power lines to
replace
spread out over virtually the entire
southern part of the province a hundred
and fifty thousand homes remain without
power and another hundred thousand in
quebec
and that's led to long lines at gas
stations provided they're open at all
demand is so high many have run dry they
came down
right onto all of the vehicles nick
mckay for one doesn't expect to get
power back anytime soon the massive
trees in the pine glen neighborhood of
ottawa where he lives were no match for
the 120 kilometer per hour winds nor
were the cars now smashed in his
driveway one of the trucks is folded in
half
the little car is completely flat
and the jeep has sustained a lot of
damage on the front there's a tree
sitting on the hood
the storm is being called one of the
most destructive in ontario's history it
cut through the most populous part of
the country with near tornado strength
winds and it moves so quickly there was
little warning as thrill seekers at
canada's wonderland found out
video posted on tick tock showed people
stuck on the massive behemoth roller
coaster for half an hour as the storm
passed through
it's a storm that knocked the top off
silos and left the etter farm in
disarray
so this pile that was that used to be a
machine shed
and also a mobile home that was on the
property
but those can be rebuilt their family
including a herd of dairy cows are alive
and well which they attribute in part to
luck on the mother nature side i mean
that's when you realize like there's
nothing we could have done except
you know hide in the basement or in a
safe space mike delay global news
toronto
in eastern manitoba spring flooding in
white shell provincial park is getting
worse residents and emergency crews are
scrambling to reinforce ring dykes and
fill sandbags to save homes cottages and
businesses before it's too late
there's so much water out there it's
overwhelming it's affecting many more
manitobans at the same time than than
maybe it has in the past
manitoba premier heather stephenson
surveyed the spring flooding today
taking an aerial tour with senior
government officials she says the area
near the ontario border is completely
surrounded by rising flood water a
mandatory evacuation order for the
northern part of white shell provincial
park is being expanded tonight
quebec's national assembly passed bill
96 late today controversial language
legislation to protect and promote the
french language by limiting the use of
english access to english services and
education courses dan spector is in
montreal tonight and dan quebec's
premier francoise ago says this is all
about the survival of french culture
chris after months of fiery debate that
divided the province bill 96 has passed
with a 78 to 29 vote at the national
assembly to thunderous applause like you
said premier france while ago saying it
is his duty to protect the french
language lest it disappear in a sea of
english in north america there have been
multiple concerns from rights groups
from anglophone groups and from the
federal government about this law's
potential to infringe on people's rights
there are concerns about access to
education access to the justice system
access to medicine in people's mother
tongue language if it is a language
other than french i'll let you take a
listen to francoise message to
anglophones they have to understand that
it's a question of survival if we don't
take action to protect french
it's a matter of time
it quebec becomes a bilingual state
it's a matter of time before we lose
the presence of french in quebec
there are expected to be legal
challenges but the bill is protected by
the not withstanding clause it's baked
right into bill 96 so that shields it
from challenges based on the charter of
rights and freedoms but legal experts
say they will chip away at certain
provisions but it could be before the
courts for years chris no doubt all
right thank you dan that's dan specter
in montreal
security experts sound the alarm coming
up why they say canada is not ready for
the security threats we're facing
[Music]
a blue chip panel of national security
experts released a stark warning today
that canada is simply not prepared to
deal with a world of growing and complex
security threats including from our
closest ally our chief political
correspondent david aiken joins us and
david it sounds like we need a complete
security overhaul here
and chris this is not just any group of
experts this group includes four former
national security advisors to prime
ministers trudeau and harper plus two
former directors of csis in other words
this group has had access to the most
secret and the best intelligence for
canada and its allies we are now
in a security environment that poses
a number of dangers for the west
including
canada whether it's economic espionage
foreign interference and domestic
politics or cyber attacks canada's
security agencies and armed forces are
not well prepared to deal with emerging
threats we're not saying that armageddon
is around the corner but you
you connect a lot of these tourettes you
put them together it's a it's a
dangerous world
canada i think not just its governments
but its people at large have not always
taken national security seriously and
canada's traditional allies may not be
the reliable bulwark they once were take
the united states for example last
year's january the sixth attack on the
u.s capitol not only threatened american
democracy but the forces behind that
attack are also seen as a threat to
canada's democracy we also have to
increasingly come to think as the us as
not only the greatest source of our
prosperity and security but also a
source of insecurity
we see it for example with growing
transnational ties between right-wing
extremists in canada and in the us the
prime minister says he agrees with the
diagnosis
we're working closely with our national
security agencies working closely with
uh organizations like the the
canadian security establishment around
communications uh to make sure
that we are able to respond to these new
issues new new realities but the experts
say that the government needs to do more
before there's a crisis on canadian soil
a good place to start they say a new
national security review the last one
was done in 2004. chris
david aiken in ottawa thank you david
the pen is mightier than the
flamethrower ahead why one of canada's
greatest novels is now fireproof
[Music]
canadian literary legend margaret atwood
has armed herself with a flamethrower to
protest censorship
the 82 year old is promoting the one-off
auction of a fully fire-resistant copy
of her novel the handmaid's tale atwood
and publisher penguin house say the
version was made in response to what
they call the challenging the banning
and even burning of hundreds of books
across the u.s
the prime minister is in bc visiting the
tecumless to schwetmick first nation as
it marks one year since it confirmed 215
unmarked presumed graves at a former
residential school trudeau met elders
and leaders in the community but not
everyone was happy to see him nitu
garcia explains
[Applause]
for many the prime minister's arrival
here monday was a surprise
he arrived to a day-long memorial event
marking one year since more than 200
unmarked burials were found near the
former kamloops indian residential
school around 4 30 pm to a mixed
reaction there were many supporters but
others didn't want him present this is
about our elders and our survivors those
who are still filled with hurt and anger
i hear that as well prime minister
trudeau fell short of making any
concrete commitments a sign of his
honest intent to focus on survivors say
some but to leaders like grand chief
stuart phillip who wants funding for
more ground-penetrating radar searches
it was a performative approach there
needs to be
a significant investment in this work
and
you know we expect the prime minister to
acknowledge that and understand that and
i heard some of the survivors saying
that like what did he really say
was this just a photo op
trudeau vowed to partner with the
community in its next steps and he
addressed the anger
what so many people have been through
in terms of layers of trauma that they
have gone through if if it makes anyone
feel a little bit better to shout at me
than please they should cook p roseanne
kasmir focusing on the importance of
moving beyond blame and working together
something amanda big sorrel horse agrees
with
i appreciate what he did say and
hopefully that he will have support to
move forward in a more positive and
impactful way for all of us not just us
as indigenous and native people but for
all canadians this is canadian history
last year prime minister trudeau faced
criticism for vacationing on vancouver
island instead of coming here for the
country's first national day for truth
and reconciliation and while he didn't
provide specifics on previous promises
like a local healing center for tacoma
loops to schwetmick he did say the
federal government will support whatever
path forward communities like this one
decide is right for them chris
all right thanks very much nithu garcia
reporting in kamloops and a reminder
there is support available for survivors
of residential schools and their
families the number is toll free
operates 24 hours a day it is
1-800-721-0066
soul food coming up next how traumatized
ukrainians are finding peace and
friendship in the kitchen
[Music]
for those who remain in ukraine life is
seemingly under constant threat but
through that trauma the kitchen is a
place where people are finding food
and friendship crystal gomencing reports
in this kitchen in kiev food is love and
with every dish comfort is served if you
worry about someone you want at first
you want to feed them
that's care that's how we care about our
loved ones everyone around this table
agrees the war has made them family and
they've been cooking for about ten
thousand extended relatives
soldiers people in hospital neighborhood
kids
anyone in need it's better than just sit
at home and scroll news and
do nothing
nothing good comes from passing time
doom scrolling on social media so in the
days following february 24th more than
two dozen cafe restaurant owners bakers
and workers decided to put their skills
to use and get to work they united to
find kitchen space food donations
and delivery drivers the main cool thing
that we did we connected people who were
panicked shocked and they were in fear
and we make their life full of sense
because they have a job they
can help and they can see results very
quickly most of the team is under 35
many left the capitol when the city was
under attack in the early days of the
full invasion
being away however made them feel
disconnected
and vulnerable when you're doing
something good when you are helping
maybe you are not realizing that first
of all you are helping yourself and then
it's like in the airplane you have to
put on the the mask on yourself first
and then for the other people
as ukraine secures more of its territory
demand is beginning to drop but key
volunteers haven't stopped they're still
cooking but also collecting and
delivering humanitarian supplies too
anything to support each other
and their extended family
crystal gamson global news
london
and that is global national for this
tuesday night i'm chris galas thanks for
watching tonight's your canada is
halifax's waterfront i'll see you back
here tomorrow hope you have a great
evening
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]